hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen I wanted
to watch something fun and stupid and
like really like shockworthy last week
and I watched Super Mario Brothers which
was bad and then I was like let's keep
this train rolling y'all let's watch
Garbage Pail Kids so it's turned from
regular November to November I don't
know anything about Garbage Pail Kids
except for when we're at conventions and
people ask what's the worst movie you've
ever reviewed Doug Walker always says
Garbage Pail Kids it's not gonna say
excited but I am NOT gonna say ready I
am a boba cat so
[Music]
okay so it's just a quick question what
the that was bad that was bad that was
good that was bad I knew this was gonna
be really bad I knew it I obviously knew
what if Doug Walker says it's the worst
thing he's ever reviewed and seen then
yeah it's gonna be bad
[Music]
it starts off and it makes no contents
there kids traveling in a garbage pail
through space great are they aliens are
they aliens or are they just dump kids
they pump it up so much captain Manzini
really pumps it up there he's like you
can never open this trash packs this
trek back she can is the wood you can't
open the trash can because it'll open
Pandora's box and Captain Manzini is
some mystical guy he's from a time
before gunpowder and before the
splitting of the atom and I had to
believe that he's traveled the world and
he's traveled all these times and these
different periods and he's gathered all
of these wonderful things that he has in
this really cool shop and I'm to believe
that the worst and the scariest and the
most untouchable one are the Garbage
Pail Kids
so garbage painful what just gross kids
Valarie vomit I choose you
Valerie vomits vomit isn't a character
trait there's one that's a nerd natch
nerd while it's a terrible name but at
least that's a character trait being
like a nerd vomiting isn't a character
trait that is a
the music and the costumes are so 80s
and then you see the bullies and they're
so Hades and to be very honest I am
gonna be honest about the things I liked
about this film and I loved the
full-figured nutso bully woman those are
my kind of guys I I can try to do an
impression of a crazy person please
those are my those are my kind of
guys real psychos
so the bullies are always picking on
Dodger and Dodgers this like 13 14 year
old and these bullies look like they're
in college there's a lot of weird age
things after he gets beaten up by the
bullies Dodger goes back to captain
Miyazaki captain Manzini captain man
Xena's like you smell like a fire
hydrant you could use a bath a fire
hydrant
so like metal he feels like metal he
feels like water and then he goes and
takes a bath and Captain Manos Suki is
just sitting there watching this kid
take a bath it's really weird he's not
the kid's father or parents he just lets
him work at the shop it's very weird
it's like a very up marty mcfly
doc relationship also captain mozzarella
is so annoying he says things like
patience is a bitter fruit but it bears
sweet fruit no patience is a bit of time
but it bears sweet fruit all the time oh
he's always just saying annoying
like that buddy does magic so I mean
okay so Dodger is tending to the shop
and the police come back and they start
this choreographed fight in the shop and
it's so bad oh let me just give you a
like an uppercut up to dabka chin
in the midst of the fighting the Garbage
Pail is knocked over and slime oozes out
and it's like well of course the one
thing that he told you not to do Dodger
it happened god damn it
so the bully's drag Dodger into a sewer
open up the sewer grate and spew sewage
all over him and then leave him in the
sewer
just because Dodger gave the bully's
girlfriend tangerine tangerine a free
pin he's like see you later creep you
just poured sewage water over a small
child I don't think you know what Creek
means the Garbage Pail Kids show up
there's an alligator there for some
reason the Garbage Pail Kids start
messing up the shop and it's just like
oh we're all doing high jinks stuff this
is the Pandora's Box the Captain
marshmallow was talking about they're
just the gross but like this that's it
back that's it okay then Dodgers also
trying to get with the bully's
girlfriend pineapple it's like what why
why why the age thing why didn't you
just cast as a younger female and
younger bullies are an older main-care
oh I hate the greaser puppet the one
who's always threatening people with a
knife he always has a knife in his hand
he's always like hey hey yeah yeah yeah
and the fun's dodger goes back he's like
I need more clothes because she liked
the jacket and so the rest of the movie
is just the Garbage Pail Kids making
clothes for Dodger and his girlfriend
cherry
persimmons it's a very sweatshop vibe
though because these are small children
and an alligator they're working down in
this basement for free child labor
sweatshop then they break out into this
random song we could get anything done
when we work with each other and it's
like ha ha they're good at making
clothes and and they also sing and
they're also the biggest evil and the
best like the biggest baddest Pandora's
box
craziest thing they were like you know
what our demographic is twelve-year-old
boys and you know what twelve-year-old
boys like stupidity and fart jokes and a
character who pees his pants 19 seconds
ha
no captain mo mo Khan has this book
that's called really black magic and
they do want that fun so then they
develop this other part of the plot
where the garbage pail kids are like our
other friends are at the state home for
the ugly
I'm trying never it doesn't matter I'm
just gonna brush past that they're like
we will we have to find them so Dodger
and Captain em go out to find it it's a
very short scene faith see it they find
it then we're like are okay people did
it and then Dodger goes to a fashion
show with Apple struggling to find other
fruits to culture so Lima betrays Dodger
and locks the Garbage Pail Kids in the
state at home for the ugly so they break
them out and then they ruin the fashion
show and then they like the whole thing
at the end is is Lima coming up to
Dodger and being like I'm so sorry that
I did that can we be friends and Dodgers
like no I don't find you
pretty anymore then all the Garbage Pail
Kids right off into the sunset on an ATV
nothing about it was fun I mean Howard
the Duck was more fun than this and
Howard the Duck is a snorefest
somebody gave this to me at the it's
screening it is a hairbrush whip there's
hair in here cuz I actually use it as a
brush as I couldn't find mine
she made it cuz I whip my hair so much
in this series I'm not what the out
of this movie though huh yeah ha ha
let's see some of these predictions you
know what actually
now let's see some of these pretty so my
friend it rocked says please don't do it
Tamra whatever they're blackmailing you
with it's not worth it em says you're
gonna cry from the awful at some point
well yeah I did actually
that was bad discomfort pain madness
pain again yuck pain regret dead run
there's really no actual prediction it's
just people being like no don't stop I
hated this film and I am kind of excited
it's fun to not like things I always
like things I'm gonna put up a pole on
my Twitter asking what I should do next
week
I've got trolls to I've got the last
airbender I've got Oh someone got
fingered Freddie get that fingered so
got a couple a couple real good gyms I'm
the one hand I'm glad that I now have
seen a movie that is really well known
as being terrible it's kind of fun to
like be in the in in that kind of sense
on the other hand this film forever you
know okay see y'all next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you